-I want to talk about
your show, as well.
-That's why I'm here, actually.
-Yeah.
I don't want you to
just use this to promote how
I blew my son's name.
"Santa Clarita Diet" --
-That's just one thing
you've done.
-Yeah.
Can I tell you the second?
Did you like
the second son's name?
-I -- Hold on.
I was listening last night.
And, by the way,
what a lovely moment.
-Oh, thank you.
-You talking about --
-Thank you.
That's very kind of you to say.
-I'm a big fan already.
There's something about
when these moments
of real life happen and comedy
happening at the same time.
It's genius.
-Well, you know --
-You know that, right?
You were part of this genius.
Anyway, I really -- I sat there.
I flew in last night.
I watched it.
-Axel. His name is Axel.
-That's the sad part.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, my God.
-You know, did you do the
whole thing where you tell --
By the way, I'm on the show
"Santa Clarita Diet."
You guys should watch it.
So, listen.
We might get time
to show a clip,
but if we don't [bleep] it.
It's really fun.
It's on Netflix.
-Drew Barrymore's in it.
Adorable. America's sweetheart.
It's a funny, funny show.
So, that's done.
So, did you tell people what
you were gonna name your kid?
-No.
-Oh, good call.
-Yeah, didn't do it.
-Because, you know,
we almost named our kid --
'Cause you see what happens.
You just saw it right here.
-Yeah, exactly.
-Yeah, we almost named --
Each time, we didn't know if we
were gonna have a boy or girl.
One of the real front-runners,
in my mind, was Angus.
-Okay, Angus.
-I was just like --
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
Okay, so, there's two people
in the world that I know about.
There's one person that's like,
"Yeah! Awesome!"
And then there's others that
are like, "Like the beef?"
-Yeah.
And, so, we didn't do it, but,
man, I just really wanted Angus.
-Yeah. We were actually
looking for "A" names.
That was the thing --
my wife wanted another "A" name,
but Angus was never
in the running.
-Not a name.
-No. It didn't come up at all.
-"A" name.
-Like, a name
that started with "A."
-Yeah, I got it.
-We were looking for "a name."
-Everybody is. Everybody is.
You're like, "All right, well,
that doesn't
make you special, Seth.
-Exactly. Exactly.
You've named them.
One's 2.
The other one's a few days old.
-Yeah.
-Nothing really of any
major importance has happened.
-Yeah. Look,
you keep establishing
that I've done nothing.
-I'm just worried,
'cause you know how this goes.
Like, in 18 years from now --
'cause I've been through this --
if it doesn't go well,
you'll know when, like,
the university is saying, "Well,
if you're willing to donate
this amount of money,
I guess we could
let the kid slide in there."
-Yeah.
-You know?
When you guys hear about the
Meyers School of Communication
at Ohio State...you'll know.
-I'll know?
-You'll know.
You know what I mean?
-We've talked enough --
"Santa Clarita Diet"...
-I mentioned it.
I know I mentioned it.
-Drew Barrymore is a zombie.
You're married to her.
You try really hard to --
-She's a zombie.
She's eating people,
and it's put a tremendous stress
on the marriage.
-But it's a very funny show,
because you --
What I love about the show is --
you remain a married couple,
and you still love her,
even though she's
a flesh-eating zombie.
-I'm trying to make
the relationship work.
-Yeah.
-We're trying to raise our
teenage daughter as normal.
We're really trying to
maintain some sense of normalcy.
And the killing
and eating people has just
put a tremendous amount
of stress on it all.
And we're also -- This season,
we're hopefully trying to
save the world, as well.
-All right.
Well, look at you guys.
-That's a lot of
balls in the air.
-Yeah.
-And we're selling real estate.
-I think anyone --
-Doesn't that sound genius?
-Anyone who watched
this interaction will know
you're one of my favorite people
to have on the show.
I can't wait for you
to come back.
Give it up for
Timothy Olyphant, everybody.